let's go to our next caller from the six
one seven area code going to six one
seven is always dicey because it's
either a local fan or a big-time Boston
right-winger you never know when you go
to the six one seven area code caller
from six one seven tell us your name
where you're calling from and what's on
your mind today
oh hi David it's me Terry again um I
just wanted to call you guys I've been
watching your videos embedded Swale
edited and I think you really are onto
something about the the significant
vocal section of the left / liberals who
really do defend on the material
government and really like to heart
basically do hardline critiques of the
opposition basically I've been reading I
usually like to read this back online
magazine called Jacobin and they use
sometimes published articles critical
but guro but this year they published
several yeah and a lot of leftists who
are really like pro Maduro have like
chata sides and even denounced the
publication for those articles so i
think it's really interesting how you
know it's how you can kind of see this
like in action and all that - yeah I
didn't hear anything wrong correct me if
I'm wrong Terry but I thought someone
recently sent me a Jacobean article
about Venezuela and I believe that it
was super Pro Maduro well I think they
have published some but they've also
published many that art see the thing
with Jaco Ben is that they don't have a
centralized editorial policy so you can
even have like situations where two
articles published by two different
people can argue two very different god
weights and all that listen for example
conceptually I may agree with that at
all rush okay yeah I mean I personally
take it in to sell the idea of having
you know allowing for dissenting views
within the publication that's great I
think that that's fantastic I agree with
you and it sounds like you're sharing my
sentiment that there may be some problem
among the left with regard to defending
the Maduro regime and you know i'm it's
not because I'm some kind of elitist
white Argentinian that I hate all other
South American countries and thus
dislike Nicolas Maduro it's
not because I'm Jewish that I criticized
the clearly anti-democratic regime of
Nicolas Maduro I'm evaluating the
situation at its face based on the facts
on the ground rather than the vague
ideas of its leftist democratic
socialism and that's where I come away
with the view I have if I'm wrong on the
facts let me know but ad hominem Zoar
the US wants Venezuelan oil that doesn't
really change the facts on the ground
you know Terry yes yeah it's actually
interesting you mention at homonyms
because I've seen my friends share a lot
of memes about the veditz book well not
all my friends but like a small section
of my friends share memes about
Venezuela and one of them is like this
picture of this pretty called Ignacio
Walker's like called Maduro and dictator
and they're like oh my gosh
Ignacio Walker was a big fan of Pinochet
during his day or there's this other
video with this guy named Louis's name
again here let me take a look work oh
yeah here we go on it Diego Araya which
apparently he had backed the 2002 coup
against Hugo Chavez they posted this
like interview that he had with Artie
and you know basically there's this guy
from the Empire files just calls them
out and you know it's like don't get me
wrong are there shady figures in the
Venezuelan opposition currently but it's
unfair dissipate the opposition like
that basically just because there are a
few bad apples I mean obviously you have
to be careful about this but that's not
the you know that's not the same thing
it's like saying that somehow Linda
Sarsour automatically undermine BLM
feminist marches and all that - yep yeah
I agree with you cherries thank thanks
so much for the call very well said very
important and of course we are not
saying that there's no criticisms to be
made of the Venezuelan opposition no
doubt about that